Hey guys i'm Abbey Sharpe, welcome to
Abbey's Kitchen. Today's "What I Eat In A Day"
YouTuber review is sponsored by Ritual and I'm gonna be reviewing vegan YouTuber
Miles Kasari from Healthy Crazy Cool. Now
before we get started, I want to talk for
a minute about my personal supplement
routine but I get that life does get
kind of crazy and it can become hard to
make sure we're getting all of the
essential nutrients that we need every
day. So a lot of people do ask me what
brand of prenatal vitamins I use and I
recently discovered Ritual vitamins
which is a vitamin subscription service
that delivers supplements to your door
and it's only about a dollar a day. This
is so nice for those of us who are
practicing social distancing or if we
just want a convenient option that we
don't have to remember to always go out
and refill. I know the supplement world
is overwhelming, but I like rituals
prenatal because it has 12 essential
nutrients to support the health of me
and baby before and during pregnancy,
including methylated fourth generation
folate, vegan b12, D3 and Omega 3, and they
have no colorants, additives, or unlisted
ingredients. It's also vegan, sugar-free,
non-GMO, gluten-free, and allergen free. So
if you're having a hard time finding a
vitamin that fits your dietary needs,
this really does have it all. Also if you
find that taking a prenatal can make you
a little bit nauseous these ones have a
no nausea capsule design so you don't
have to take them necessarily with food.
You can check out the link in the
description to get 10% off your first
three months on Ritual. Now let's get
into the video.
Okay so Miles is a vegan YouTuber with
almost 200,000 YouTube subscribers, who
describes himself as the "Tahini King". I
mean just watch a few of his videos and
you'll get what I'm saying about that.
Actually it was Miles who inspired me to
switch up how I do these "what I at in a dat"
videos to make them a little bit more
inclusive and extensive. I assume he
still wouldn't approve especially
because I'm now doing one on him, but I
do think this format ensures we make it
more about the diet and what we can
learn from it rather than the person
itself. Which, as you know, was never my
goal to begin with. So if you're liking
this format, definitely don't
forget to subscribe so that you don't
miss out on any of my upcoming content.
Now before we get into today's video too
much, a gentle reminder that this video
is for education and entertainment
purposes only and is not meant in any
way to diagnose or prescribe any way of
eating so you should always speak to a
registered dietitian or doctor about
your specific needs.
Okay so you heard about my supplements,
let's kick things off by looking at his.
Yeah I take the Omega 3 just as
kind of a good balance and the b12
because I'm vegan and like I've said
before if you're a vegan who doesn't take
b12, you're not just a vegan you're a
dickhead.
Oh my god, so I kind of love this guy
already but yes I'm happy to hear that
he's promoting taking your vitamin d3
and b12 and omega-3. Really what I think
would be the most important vitamins for
any plant-based person but also for most
omnivores as well. So let's see what
we're having for breakfast on day one.
Alrighty so here's my
brunch? Lunch?
I don't even know what to call it.
I'm gonna give it a little sprinkle of hemp
seeds for extra crunch some, omega 3s,
extra protein. You guys know I put hemp
seeds on absolutely everything whether
it's sweet or savory.
This half is the potato salad.
I also forgot to tell you
obviously I put in salt and pepper not
about to make any kind of meal without
salt and pepper. I don't understand
these salt-free people it's just fucking
crazy.
I saved back some of the steamed greens
just to have extra Greenidge, extra
greens on the side. Now this is a very
creamy potato salad because obviously
you've got the nutty earthy beautiful
tahini "liquid gold", but it's also very
tangy and pungent from the dill and the
lemon and all of the other flavors, and
you get the crunch from the celery. It's
just perfect. Okay, so that looks super
delish.
I think we're kindred spirits in that we
both put hemp hearts on everything. But I
mean, if we really want to talk balance
we could add a little more protein in
this, maybe throw in some silken tofu in
the dressing, or serve it with a side of
seared tofu, but at least we're getting a
little from the hemp and
tahini. I also have to say I love how
Miles describes food. Between his ode to
Sharon fruit earlier on in the video and
then just the way he's talking and
walking us through this meal, he really
gets the sensuality of food and even
something as humble as a potato salad
sounds so incredible when he describes
it. Let's take a look at day two.
Whenever I do have like regular coffee which is like not regularly, I actually don't feel
like it gives me energy. I feel like it
makes me anxious for 20 minutes and then
I just feel tired. So again, I don't drink
coffee for energy, I eat good food for energy.
Yes! Oh my gosh. I see so many YouTubers
who buzz through their day just sipping
their green tea lattes and energy drinks
and it's really refreshing to hear
someone say "hey I drink coffee because
I like the flavor and I eat food with
calories aka energy for energy" Alright, let's
see what he's gonna eat. Some frozen
bleubs. Love myself some frozen bluebs,
specially on hot food like the contrast
between the hot squishy potatoes, then
you get like the icy crunch a little bit
of tartness from the frozen berries. Love it.
Now, it is my duty as the one and only
nut butter king to smother this with
some good runny, and kind of clumpy today, almond butter. Almond butter. You can, of course,
use any nut butter you have lying
around. You can use peanut butter, you can
use cashew butter, you can also use
tahini or sunflower seed butter if you
don't do nuts
or if you're allergic to nuts. This is
one of the things, in fact the main thing,
that I find makes my meals are lot more
filling and satiating it just keeps me
full up and satisfied is adding a good
amount of fat and protein to my meals.
And obviously almond butter is a great
source of fat and protein, very high in
protein for a nut, and to be honest it's
just delicious. This is coconut yogurt which is very thick and
creamy. I love it, it's the best coconut yogurt.
and yeah what I did to make this
yogurt higher in protein
I added half a scoop of the Madagascan
vanilla viva life protein powder and not
only does that make the meal a lot more
satisfying because again we bumped up
the protein, but it bumps up the flavor
as well because that vanilla flavor. Also
going to add a sprinkle of hemp seeds,
you guys know I put hemp seeds on
absolutely everything. I've spent the last 15
minutes trying to make this look
Instagrammable, but clearly I failed.
Cheers!
Oh my gosh that looks awesome, and I love
that he talks about the importance of
adding a good amount of fat and protein
to meals to boost up satiety. I love this
guy, I mean he may kind of hate me, but I
think he's a lot like me but in a cute
British man form. Let's take a look at
day three. So yeah, I don't normally have
a avo toast for breakfast. I'm getting
back onto like savory breakfasts, like I
think I said in my last "what I eat in a day"
that like when I was in Bali I... guys, I
ate more fruit than freelee, like you have
no idea. And I'd love to start with fruit
right? But the thing is, it just it just
opens up a black hole and, I don't know,
it's just a thing. But I'm really getting
back onto savory breakfasts and just
really loving avocado toast.
That looks so good that it hurts my soul
not to be eating it right now.
I am also obsessed with sourdough
anything and that's a nice generous
portion of some delicious looking
sourdough avocado toast. Now, also I'm
happy to hear that he's switching up his
breakfast and not just having fruit. I'm
not really sure exactly what he means by
a "black hole" situation. Maybe that the
fruit kind of goes right through him and
it gives him the runs, or that it leaves
him like super hungry soon after. Either
way, I am happy to see a more substantial
breakfast with some more slow-burning
carbs and healthy fats in here, with the
avocado and of course that beautiful
sourdough bread. I mean if he wanted he
could use my technique of mashing some
white beans into his avvocato to boost
up the protein, but I get not everyone is
crazy about having a lot of protein in
the morning and this is a huge step up
in my opinion from just having fruit.
Okay, now let's talk about my overall
thoughts on breakfast. All of these are
crazy delicious looking breakfasts. He
definitely is
a carb lover in the morning. So with
the exception of day two, we could
definitely boost up the protein a little
bit for better satiety, which I know is
really important for Miles. But hey, this
is why we look at the entire day and if
he's gonna pick it up on the protein
later on in the day I am 100% cool with
a high carb morning. I mean that is when
most of us actually need a little energy
kick, and I really appreciate that Miles
relies on food not just caffeine to get
that fix. Let's take a look at meal two. The
base of this is two large heads of
romaine. Yes, this is a giant bowl. We all
know I love my romaine that refreshing
crunch, and then we got the crispy tofu,
soft avocado, the spicy kimchi, lots of
crunchy pine nuts. Yes, I mean, it's a very
simple salad yet full of goodness
proteins, healthy fats, kimchi so good for
your gut, lots of greens, but the best
part - let's douse it in some of the
dressing. And honestly, this dressing has
come out absolutely perfect. It's actually the first time that I tried it but it's bomb.
So I'll leave the full exact measurements
that I use down below. This also looks
incredible.
I love that we have some protein in the
tofu, healthy fats in the avocado, nuts,
and of course tahini, and the added
probiotic benefits of kimchi in there.
Not a lot of carbs going on and that is
totally actually cool considering he had
a super higher carb meal at breakfast or
brunch or whatever he wants to call it
that day so this is why you kind of have
to look at the entire day as a whole.
Taken together, we are definitely
covering all of our bases with this
awesome looking meal. Let's take a look
at day two. And a whole large cucumber.
Gonna toss the potatoes and the tofu
with this little refreshing mix and then
we've got the green sauce for the top.
And you all know, you should all know, the
cameras wonky but I don't care, that
when I eat lunch another one of my big
tips for people that are just always
hungry is to eat a lot of fiber, a lot of
fibrous veggies, a lot of greens.
I would usually always with my lunch, and
my dinners sometimes,
eat like a lot of romaine lettuce,
spinach, kale, maybe some steamed broccoli,
or green beans, lots of fibrous greens to
kind of bulk up the meal. Okay, so like
his other lunch this looks amazing.
I would kill for this right now and I
love the combination of kind of hot and
cold and creamy and refreshing. We've got
lots of fiber in the veggies and the
fruit, we got fat in the dressing and the
avocado, and protein from the tofu. And I
agree everything is more delicious in
some kind of taco vessel so that looks
super bomb. Let's take a look at day
three. Alright, here's the final result
this tofu is just so perfectly crispy,
and then these broccoli, broccolini,
whoever is these florets, are so nice and
caramelized and that's because of the
coconut aminos.
I often roast in balsamic vinegar or
balsamic glaze as well if I want things
to get like really sweet and caramelized,
but coconut aminos does the job even
better. Then I've just got some purple
cabbage as per use, and underneath
remember that huge bowl of kale I showed
you? Which is in one of my huge like
huge huge bowls, they all wilted down
kind of cooked down but became nice and
tender
just through the process of massaging it
with the avocado, the coconut aminos, and
the lime juice. All it needs, of course, is
a good drizzle of liquid gold. Another
killer lunch,
I mean we've got loads of beautiful
colorful vegetables, we've got our
protein in the tofu, healthy fats from
the avocado, olive oil, and tahini. Lots of
great things going on and it looks
insanely good. Also, I just picked up a
new tip, I never thought to roast with
coconut aminos. So yeah, thanks Miles I'm
totally gonna be checking that out. Let
me give you my thoughts on his lunches.
So Miles honey, can you invite me to
lunch sometime because I want what you
are having. Now I am so happy to see a
little bit more protein action happening
with a second meal. It is becoming clear
to me that Miles may not know that he's
doing this, but he's actually really well
balancing out his day nicely
with carbs and protein. I mean it is a
bit repetitive as he tends to rely
mainly on tahini for fat, tofu for
protein, and potatoes for carbs, but I get
that sometimes you just like what you
like. I am happy to see him switching up
his preparation of the ingredients and
serving them all into interesting and
delicious looking meals. Let's take a
look at his snacks. I'm impressed
it does smell like orange Nutella. Man, I
love chocolate orange. I miss Terry's
chocolate orange so much. Cheers!
This is the kind of thing, like, even if
you cracked her open on date night, like
you just would not share. I am dying.
I love that he has an erect penis over
this chocolate orange peanut butter, even
though I admittedly do not like the
combination of orange and chocolate and
I think Terry's chocolate orange is just
gross. But, I get that it's totally a love
or hate a thing, and if you have a strong
opinion on this like me or like Miles
please leave me a comment below about
where you stand.
Are you team chocolate orange or not? I
totally want to know. Let's take a look
at day two. Some good old cel. Do you
know what guys, I reckon this is actually
gonna be bomb. I have a feeling. Cheers!
So I love that
Miles reviews different nourishing
satiating snacks and macadamia nuts are
rich in healthy fats, manganese, and fiber,
as well as tons of flavonoid
antioxidants. Plus they taste legit
amazing, and are for sure at one of my
favorites so I am confident, without even
trying it, that that macadamia nut butter
would be so good. Let's take a look at
day three. I'm so excited to see all
these different nut butter spreads.
I mean chai spiced peanut butter, it does
sound kind of weird, but with this brand
you just never want to write them off.
Also, I don't have any celery today
which is kind of criminal so instead we
are going in with a carrot. Cheers!
Jeeze, the flavors in this. All I can say
about this.
Oh my gosh, it's like Christmas but
spreadable. I feel like I need this now I
am obsessed with chai so hey Norty, if
you want to ship up to Canada please hit
me up. Also says that he has an apple
after that which I think would be really
tasty with the chai peanut butter so
that would be a nice duo if he wanted to
combine the two.
Let me tell you my overall thoughts on
his snacks. Okay so you guys know my
thoughts on a healthy snack, I always try
to look for one or more of what I call
the "hunger crushing combinations" so
that's fiber, protein, and healthy fats.
Well, even though all of these snacks are
basically the same, they are nut butter, I
have to say they all fit that criteria
perfectly. Nuts, in general, are a perfect
package snack because they have
plant-based protein, fiber for regularity
and heart health, and those awesome
monounsaturated fats. Also, I need to try
this brand because these nut butters
would be so delicious and so fun in
oatmeal, yogurt, or pancakes. I could think
of so many great recipes to make with
them. Alright, let's talk about dinner.
Avocado and Marmite on toast and a
protein shake. So, I'm gonna show you what
I ate on another evening this week instead
as it's much more exciting. The best
vegan pizza I've ever had in my life.
Okay, so Miles actually had avocado toast
with Marmite and a protein shake for
dinner but he, instead, shows us a super
yummy that he had another night which
looks awesome, by the way.
But the truth is there's, nothing wrong
with the boring meal he actually had.
I like that we have some healthy fats from
the avocado, carbs from the toast, and
protein in the protein shake. I mean even
if it's not fancy or Instagrammable or
Youtube-able in this case, I like that he
still has a good balance of macros.
Sometimes I just really like the
realness of "hey I was alone tonight and
didn't feel like a elaborate fancy meal so
this is what hit the spot". I mean, there
are lots of nights where I eat like
Greek yogurt and oatmeal and I'm okay
with that. Let's take a look at day two.
Which isn't a vegan place but they do
have a new vegan menu and what they were
to be honest but it was bomb and when I
say bomb I mean that the heat from the
spices almost blew my head off. Chickpea
flour dumplings this pancake potato dosa
thing, which was super tasty, and also
these little shots of spiced carrot soup.
I had these pancake wraps which were
filled with vegan cheese, quinoa, lots of
different veggies, and to be honest I
have no idea what else was in there. Oh I
am totally craving Indian right now that
looks like an amazing feast. I love that
unlike a lot of YouTubers, Miles is not
afraid of eating out and it doesn't seem
to impact his diet earlier on the day
like we sometimes see. By that I mean he
doesn't restrict calories or portions to
save calories for a big binge later.
Considering some of the YouTubers that
I've reviewed recently, I really
appreciate that. What this tells me is
that even though miles may say he isn't
really able to eat intuitively, which
I'll talk about soon, I actually think he
may have greater skills than he thinks
and can respond to his hunger cues, enjoy
food, be social, and not punish himself
for it later. I am not seeing this
extreme restrict-binge situation that I
see with so many other wellness
YouTubers. Let's take a look at day three.
Quinoa and black bean burgers which
come with the most amazing caramelized
onions. We also got some salad because
you can never eat dinner without greens,
in my opinion, and also this really
amazing creamy coleslaw.
So we went to the best vegan ice cream
place in London called "Yorica". Anyways,
after being one of those annoying people
who asks to try every flavor, I got a
scoop of coffee and a scoop of coconut.
So lots of delicious looking stuff going
on here. I love, first of all, that he said
you know you can't eat dinner without
greens. Honey, you are basically an
honorary dietitian in my books. Second, I
am also that annoying person who samples
every single ice cream. I mean, how can
you possibly commit if you do not try.
And finally, I love that he said to
nourish your body but also your soul.
Miles, I get you. Now let's talk about my
overall thoughts on his dinners. So, a lot
of you might be thinking "Well, what he's
eating for dinner isn't very healthy how
could Abbey possibly approve?" This is
actually a breath of fresh air to me in
this perfect obsessive vegan youtube
diet world. Folks, when you're eating this
many beautiful colorful vegetables, slow
burning carbohydrates, plant-based
proteins and healthy fats for breakfast
lunch and your snacks, you're gonna hit
your nutrient needs. So there is no need
to sweat it out if you dine out for that
you know every other meal once in a
while if that is what brings you joy. I
actually like that Miles gives us a
realistic look at what a balanced normal
relaxed vegan diet could look like.
And since Miles discusses his needs to
keep close tabs on his macros and
calories sometimes, I think it's great to
see him kind of loosen the reins a bit
to dine out and enjoy that time with
friends.
So is this diet balanced? I would
absolutely say yes. I'm actually seeing a
really nice macronutrient distribution
between Miles days. As well as, a solid
sense of flexibility in his lifestyle,
which is really refreshing in the
youtube vegan community. If he opts for a
carb heavy breakfast, his lunch tends to
be higher in protein and fat with a
solid variety of fresh fruits and
vegetables enjoyed throughout. He's also
not explicitly demonizing any
ingredients and isn't afraid to enjoy a
social meal out with friends without it
fueling some kind of restrict-binge
cycle. Miles you are a cool guy. Now is
there anything missing in his diet? I
don't really think so I mean he is
taking his b12, D, and omega-3s, and
his meals are impossibly healthy-looking.
So folks, if you want some vegan
inspiration you know where to look. Now, I
also want to touch on some awesome
things that I think we can definitely
take away from Miles this channel. First
of all, he's not afraid of oil. So there
have been a lot of YouTubers that I've
reviewed lately that are explicitly
avoiding oils.
I've done a whole video on this looking
at the research for and against that
argument. So definitely check that out
right here. But I am happy to see Miles
have a smart, yet not obsessive, approach
to added oils. Sometimes, like for the
dressing he made with tahini, he doesn't
use oil because the fat from the tahini
is enough to build body and carry the
rest of the ingredients. And sometimes,
like when he's roasting vegetables and
tofu, he uses enough to coat the
vegetables and ingredients so that they
crisp up and get nice and brown. This in
my books, is a smart use of oil. I too
don't like a really oily salad dressing,
that's a personal thing, but I do pan
sear or roast with oil because otherwise
you just never gets that rich
caramelized flavor and color that we're
looking for when we roast foods. So I
would say that this is a really smart
use of oil in my books and definitely
something that others could look towards.
Number two, he gives some great tips on
how to build a satisfying meal
physically and emotionally. In several of
his videos Miles discusses that he has a
seemingly insatiable appetite but what
he has learned from trial and error is
that there are a few things that make
his food more satisfying. He specifically
aims to make sure that there's good
protein, good carbs, and good fat.
Basically echoing what I said about the
"hunger crushing combination". And you can see that apparent in his food choices,
which is great. But he also talks about
the meal components that are not
nutritionally based. So the color, the
crunch, the variety, the flavor. What he's
talking about is emotional satisfaction
in that something could be straight-up
super satiating physically but if it's
not appealing emotionally you'll still
go searching for something else,
something more. So kudos for actually
breaking down both elements that go into
building our true satisfaction.
Number three, he doesn't judge people based on their dietary choices. It's kind of
really disappointing to be very honest
the amount of comments I've gotten
recently about like, you know, one of my
very close friends who you're gonna see
in this video, like "oh my god are you
still friends with her you know she's
not
vegan anymore how can you hang out with
someone like that", and it's like I can't
believe there are people in this world
that love people just for what they put
in their mouth. Like I'm telling you
right now, none of my friends, none of my
friends, are my friends because we're
just vegan. It's really sad that there
are still people in this world who kind
of have that division of who they hang
out with based on what they send down
the chute. It makes me really sad. And the
fact that I've got so many comments
about this one person saying "oh my god
like are you still friends with her are
you still gonna hang out with her
because she's not vegan", and it's like
number one offended that you would even
assume or question that I'm that shallow.
And number two, like get some help.
Yes! But can we get more vegans like you,
and fewer vegans like Freelee in this
world, please. But honestly, we're all just
trying our best here and figuring out
what is good to eat is such a personal
choice. So I love that Miles doesn't
discriminate against friends of his who
maybe don't share his same food
philosophies. Honestly, I don't care what
your dietary beliefs are, these are the
kind of friends I want in my life.
Number four, his recipes just look
amazing. I mean this is really a big
enough reason to watch Miles, I think his
recipes are delicious looking and simple.
And I would happily eat anything he
makes and would love to go out for a
meal with him because the guy totally
knows how to order. Now are there any
problematic claims being made by Miles? I
mean, I didn't hear anything that I would
flag us perpetuating misinformation.
I actually think Miles is super
thoughtful about the information he
shares and the language that he uses.
In fact, there was one point where he kind
of nonchalantly says the word "junk food"
and then in his edit he clarifies what
he meant by that so that he wouldn't
offend anyone. I mean I get you Miles, it
is really hard to be an influencer these
days and I am NOT going to judge you for
saying "junk food".
I'm just happy that you're so purposeful
about the information that you would put
out there into the world. So thank you
for that. Now I do think it's important
to address some of Miles as thoughts on
intuitive eating to clear a few things
up. So Miles recently made a video called
"Being on a diet is okay intuitive eating
is dangerous for some of us including me".
I'm just going to dive in and respond to
a few of the points he makes. Because
intuitive eating, even though I agree
with a lot of the principles behind it,
it doesn't work for everyone. So Miles,
we're actually not that different, you
know. I have constantly clarified based
on my own learning that intuitive may
not be for everyone. In fact, I mentioned
this at the beginning of every intuitive
eating video that I produce. I also tell
people that we can kind of choose what
aspects of intuitive eating works for us,
but I do believe that at least some of
the principles apply to all of us. Namely,
things like respecting our body, gentle
nutrition, discovering the satisfaction
factor, coping with your emotions with
kindness, etc. But there are a lot of
flaws in the intuitive eating model if
followed by the book. Specifically, that
it doesn't account for all pre-existing
health care concerns and also
socioeconomic status. Let's see what else
he has to say. But there's a big
difference, there's a big difference
between someone that is severely
orthorexic
very obsessed with food and will only
eat certain things at certain times
versus someone that is conscious and
mindful and knows what is best for their
body therefore plans their meals
accordingly, and wisely, and intelligently,
and I don't have a fourth word but, you
know what I mean. 100% and this is
actually baked into the intuitive eating
model, but I get how miles is unsure of
this as intuitive eating has kind of
been positioned by a lot of critics as
just eat whatever you want, whenever you
want, donuts all day every day. There is
actually still a consideration for
nutrition worked into this way of eating.
Not only through one of the principles,
in itself, which I'll speak more about in
a moment, but because planning your meals
and being thoughtful about your
meals is a really great way to keep your
hunger and fullness managed in a way
that feels good.
So for example, if I don't plan my lunch
out it's not the end of the world but it
may mean I let myself getting more
hungry than I comfortably would
otherwise. And then I have to make more
frantic decisions about what to eat
once it gets to that uncomfortable state.
This is what intuitive eating is really
trying to prevent but in the most
compassionate, non-judgmental way
possible. So if I eat more one day
because I didn't plan - oh well. You know,
I'll bank the information for next time
and I'll move along. Let's see what else
he has to say. With intuitive eating
it's kind of all against you know no
calorie counting there's no time a place
for calorie counting. You know the
emphasis should not be on weight loss
and in my opinion this is bollocks. If
you are severely overweight, yes the
emphasis should be on weight loss for
your health. Drastic action needs to be
taken when your health is in a drastic position.
Okay so here's
where I stand on this. There may be
intuitive eating practitioners who say
this is the protocol for everyone
regardless of your current health status
or goals, but personally I do believe
that it requires an individualized
approach. Not everyone can follow all of
the principles in order and feel
comfortable giving themselves that
freedom to eat ad libitum when they
don't really have proper hunger or
fullness cues, or when their health is
currently in a concerning place. As for
as comment about eating yourself to 300
pounds, what I will say is that like
hunger cues for Miles,
sometimes fullness sensations are also
complicated and cloudy for some people.
One thing I would be curious about is
whether or not the food choices of
someone, like who Miles is referencing,
are both stating physically and
satisfying psychologically. When these
things are constantly at odds, overeating
is way more likely to occur. So for
example, maybe we're using food as a
coping mechanism and relying a lot on
refined carbohydrates that are really
tasty but not fueling our body with the
protein, healthy fats, or fiber that it
needs to feel satiated and energized.
So personally, I believe that some people
may need to work with a dietitian who
can help build out some structure to get
those hunger and fullness cues back, help
them understand their emotional eating and mouth eating cues, educate on the types
of food that are both satisfying and
satiating, and ultimately encourage
the client to trust their body in the
baby steps that they're really
comfortable with. There's also an
interesting kind of disclaimer here he's
got.
Okay so I think like a lot of people who
criticize intuitive eating, I'm not sure
Miles has actually read the book in its
entirety and notice that there's a whole
principle on nutrition. Of course
intuitive eating may not be as much of a
numbers game as other diets, but it
doesn't make it a free-for-all eating
fest. In fact, in my experience, a lot of
the people who feel really relaxed about
intuitive eating do have a solid
knowledge of nutrition. The difference,
however, between somebody who feels
comfortable with intuitive eating who
has this nutrition knowledge, and someone
who ends up in orthorexic territory, is
that they don't punish themselves for
this knowledge. Now I want to flag that
the reason why nutrition is left until
some of the foundational principles are
ironed out, is that when you're stuck in
"restriction mode" any choices based on
"nutrition" are still coming from a place
of restriction that is just not
sustainable. So once you work through the
process of letting go of the diet voice
in your head, you can make decisions
about what to eat that not only take
into account what looks good or a tastes
good, but what feels good to your body
and honors your health and nutritional
needs. Being on a diet, being on a healthy
diet is a good thing, and also the word
again the word "diet" can be taken in so
many different ways because when we hear the word "diet" we think of restriction,
lack of calories, severe weight loss, but
it actually when I think of the word
diet it means just a way of eating that
either supports or damages your health.
It's essentially a lifestyle. I think the
most important point I want to make in
this video is that for certain people,
like me, it is absolutely impossible to
intuitive eat
long term. Maybe in the future I can do
it right? But as someone that has
stretched my stomach to the absolute max
by just bingeing on like I can't even
explain how much food like back in the
day, as someone that went through periods
of starvation, as someone that went
through periods of massively
over-exercising, I'm talking like three
four hours a day in the gym. You know, as
someone that has formerly been addicted
to drugs, I know this video is gonna get
demonetized for me saying
word but, I'm just being real here. As
someone that has been on so many
different medications for my physical
health problem, for those of that
don't know, I had a disease
of high adrenaline it's very rare it's
called pheochromocytoma. Okay so I think
it's worth mentioning that while I do
believe everyone can incorporate at
least some of the principles of
intuitive eating, like I mentioned, not
everyone's eating and food history or
even their current medication or health
status allows them to just jump in
unassisted. Some people need to be guided a bit with some support by a dietitian
with structured meals and snacks, about
four or five a day, until you can get
that hunger and fullness sensitivity
back. And if you're currently on
medication that blunts those cues, then
you may actually need to continually and
mindfully eat those consistent meals to
make sure your body is getting enough
nutrition. This is something I definitely
think a dietitian can help people with,
but it looks to me like Miles is doing
exactly just that on his own. He knows
his body's needs and has a good base
knowledge on nutrition, and he's
nourishing himself accordingly,
even if his medical history prevents him
from feeling those regular hunger cues
very well. So some people will just not
easily ever feel comfortable eating
intuitively for a variety of reasons, not
just medication. You know, it's not a
perfect foolproof model. But that does
not mean that Miles can't incorporate at
least some of these principles and, like
I said, I actually think he's doing a
great job of that. I know for a fact that
when my anxiety is very very high, it
makes me feel physically sick.
It makes me feel like I can't even look
at food, and on those days I have to be
conscious and wise and if it gets to 1
p.m. 2 p.m. I'm still not hungry, I have
to be like okay I know my body is on
some kind of roller coaster right now,
but I need to eat because if I don't I'm
gonna spiral down further. And again,
essentially that goes against intuitive
eating because my body is telling me not
to eat, yet I know I need to. After years
and years of
abuse, my body deserves this. And if I
were to intuitive eat I'd be lost.
Okay so this is another common concern
amongst a lot of people when it comes to
intuitive eating. But intuitive eating is
not just about listening and responding
to hunger cues. It's also about self-care
and gentle nutrition. And it sounds like
Miles actually has a really good sense
that if he just lets his hunger guide
him, he won't eat enough and he knows
that.
So using that knowledge, he's choosing to
nourish his body because he knows it
will make him feel emotionally and
physically better if he does. Like I said
earlier, intuitive eating is ultimately a
bit of a privileged concept and it
doesn't account very well for food
insecurity and illness, which is what
Miles seems to be describing here. So as
I mentioned in my updated view post on
intuitive eating and health at every
size, I don't believe you're doing
anything wrong if you can't follow each
of the principles of intuitive eating to
a tee. This process can really meet you
where you are and we can learn how to
integrate the principles and components
that work for each of us. And on that
note folks, that is all from me today. A
big thank you again to Ritual for
sponsoring this video. So you can check
out the link in the description
Ritual.com/SHARP10 and use my promo code SHARP10 to get 10% off your first three
months on Ritual. If you liked it be sure
to give it the thumbs up, leave me a
comment below with your thoughts on any
YouTubers that you want me to review,
subscribe to the channel and I will see
you next time on Abbey's Kitchen. Bye!